thank you
[Music]
Avatar frontiers of Pandora is an
exciting open world action adventure
experience when playing it on PC you'll
enjoy state-of-the-art features that
will immerse you in the Wonders and
dangers of Pandora
[Music]
you are new are you not to this world
Ray Trace Reflections and shadows will
bring the world to a whole new level of
beauty and realism
preview and fine-tune your performance
for stunning visuals with extended
graphic settings
and with our built-in PC Benchmark tools
players can test their settings in a
controlled environment to compare
results and optimize their experience
AMD fsr2 can also be used to fine-tune
the balance between visual quality and
performance
the game can handle most resolutions and
aspect ratios even Ultra wide screens
are high resolution multi-monitor setups
we must bring the fights to them
players can enjoy a smooth experience
stable FPS and low latency in all
resolutions they can even expect a
higher frame rate with the right
settings and the latest Hardware the
game takes advantage of High Core count
processors as it has been optimized to
perform on Lower specs and high-end PCS
alike with its many other options and
features implemented AMD and Ubisoft are
pushing the envelope of Technical and
visual quality in gaming the fight for
Pandora has never been so captivating
immerse yourself in the extraordinary
world of Avatar frontiers of Pandora on
PC
foreign
[Music]